several weeks ago a video showing yiga
blade master
straight up stealing the master sword
took the breath of the wild community by
storm
while it's generally explained that you
just have to bring the yiga blade
masters to the korok forest
to get them to steal the sword exactly
how does this happen
here is why they steal the master sword
and how they do it step by step
and some troubleshooting during the
process if you want more videos
explaining how new breath of the wild
discoveries work
in depth let us know by liking this
video
first found by a twitter user by the
name of bot w back in january 2021
the execution of this trick since then
has become more streamlined after its
initial find
first you'll need to access the yiga
hideout while the yiga are still present
if you have defeated koga the hideout
will be empty and the blade masters will
start spawning in the overworld so you
can't do this trick if koga is defeated
this hideout also won't be active
until you start the divine beast von
nabors quest so you need to have talk to
riju in gerudo town first
now that the yiga are active we head to
the hideout with the goal of drawing the
yiga outside with you
but instead of going in through the
front door of the hideout we instead go
through the rear door
there are two ways to get the yiga's
attention through the back door
one is by shield clipping through the
wall by shield jumping onto this wall to
get skew
then forward shield jumping onto this
wall and unequipping your shield
mid-jump
this will force link straight through
the wall then simply go around to the
right here and fire an arrow at any yiga
member
after they are alerted head back and
climb up the left side of the secret
door
and you're out i recommend killing off
the foot soldiers and most of the blade
masters as you don't really need all of
them
then start climbing and walking towards
a korok forest
you'll want to keep in mind is that how
blade masters work is that they will
teleport to you when you change
elevation and they can't make a straight
walking path to you
otherwise they will continue to walk
very very slowly towards you
so before you walk the entire way to the
korok forest this way which is agonizing
i'm going to suggest using a different
method the better method is first
acquiring the moon jump glitch
by going to the mounted archery mini
game then mounting a wild horse and
staying on it until the timer ends
you'll acquire moon jump
so get the glitch first then teleport to
the tower or use a travel medallion here
if you don't want to walk
all the way to the door when you arrive
jump
throw and switch weapons to get rid of
the grounded slide glitch
then do the alternate method of getting
the ego's attention by whistling here
with your camera turned this way
the blade master will then walk to the
door to search for the noise
use a korok leaf through the wall and
this will alert the others
the difference with this method is it's
taking advantage of the teleportation
trigger by moon jumping five or six
times then falling back down
they'll have thanked you moved on to a
new platform triggering them to teleport
to you
which is much faster than the previous
method you can even loop this several
times
just by jumping a couple times as a
teleport to you now it's still a long
journey but instead of
two hours it's now maybe about 30 to 45
minutes of walking
take this path shown here to the master
[Music]
sword
[Music]
[Music]
a couple tips as you're traveling you'll
want to keep majora's mask on to reduce
random encounters and you'll want some
decent weapons to keep annoying baddies
at bay
you'll also want a good understanding of
the pros and cons of moon jump
such as normal walking speeds in snow
and sand which is great
but also the drawbacks of bumping into
anything or stepping up a curb
you'll be completely stuck at walking
speeds which is a prime time for a blade
master to one shot you
hold an item in your hands and run if
this happens you'll also need to keep
the camera trained on the blade masters
as they will sometimes despawn and
disappear if you don't
so you'll need to walk with the camera
pointed backwards you'll get used to it
now after a nice long walk and reaching
the korok forest go through the forest
as usual following the wind
it's extra important that you don't mess
up this part as getting lost in the fog
will ruin your run
now that you've reached the master sword
you're not quite done yet the korak
forest and other notable places such as
towns and stables
are considered safe zones where enemies
will usually stray away from
and their ai completely stops to
navigate around this we take advantage
of the blade masters need to confiscate
everything in sight
by dropping a bomb in front of them and
making a breadcrumb trail to the master
sword
once it's close enough to the sword they
spot it and consider it as any other
dropped weapon in need of confiscating
and voila it will approach it and steal
it
[Music]
don't worry though if you reload the
game the sword will be back to normal
which you then can just steal yourself
anyways with another recently found easy
glitch that just yoinks the sword out of
the ground for yourself
the master sword really just can't catch
a break
now you know exactly how this process
works and what you need to do to do it
yourself
if you're curious about other things you
don't know or want more breakdowns
check out our breath of the wild experts
series playlist showing you new and
interesting things
and for everything else gaming stay
tuned right here on gamespot
you